on ne peut pas mettre tout un pays sous
cloche à des ternes âme ça n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui les français ne
l'accepterai plus ce serait ce sera
peut-être nécessaire
vous voyez bien que que tout le monde
conserve cette arme
le confinement est ainsi un levier
auquel nous devons recourir quand on ne
peut pas faire autrement il faut le
faire à bon escient au bon moment et
dans la bonne mesure il faut tout faire
pour le retarder pour laisser à la
vaccination
le temps de produire des effets on ne
peut pas tout de suite aller vers un
confinement parce qu'on sait les
contraintes supplémentaires que ça
impose aux français et donc des mesures
alternatives très forte et déjà
contraignantes ont été mises en place
que ce soit le couvre feu généralisé ou
der confinement locaux le gouvernement
veut mettre en place des mesures rapides
et fortes dans les départements où la
situation se dégrade
on voit en rouge écarlate et en noir les
zones où le taux d'incidence c'est à
dire le nombre de cas positifs pour
100000 habitants est le plus élevé les
hôtes france l'île de france le grand
est et la région paca sont
particulièrement sous tension nous
plaçons donc ces départements
surveillance renforcée j'ai demandé aux
préfets des départements concernés
d'engager des concertations avec les
élus en vue d'inviter sans attendre
tous les habitants à la plus grande
vigilance et d'envisager dans tout ou
partie de ce territoire des mesures de
freinage proches de celles mises en
place à nice et dunkerque
c'est le constat d'un échec dramatique
pour le pays parce que c'est la
troisième fois que le gouvernement nous
conduit dans le mur si la situation
continue à se dégrader
nous prendrons des mesures renforcées
qui entreront en vigueur à compter du
week-end du 6 mars
ce que je demande simplement c'est que
dans les territoires où le taux
d'incidence est le plus simple que le
couvre feu se soit déclaré je demandais
ce qu'il passe au moins 19 heures et si
possible à 20 heures faisons confiance
dans les départements les moins touchés
à ce que au moins le midi sur la
restauration dite
utile par rapport à l'arrestation
plaisir qu'ils puissent effectivement
manger dans les restaurants le midi si
c'est pour desserrer pendant une semaine
et prendre le risque derrière la
situation de soi plus contrôlable je
pense que là on prendrait un risque
inconsidéré
une fois par mois le mercredi et en
direct sur les plateformes twitch ou sur
youtube le porte parole du gouvernement
compte recevoir cinq jeunes de
préférence des influenceurs dans un
studio dans une annexe de l'elysée hier
soir les invités et l influence aux
angels phoenix fabian à notre
influenceurs maire de bron dans la
métropole lyonnaise a été attaqué hier
en fin d'après midi l'élu a publié une
vidéo regardée d'un véhicule de la
municipalité fortement endommagées par
plusieurs individus
je ne sais pas si un moment devra en
continu ou pas peut-être qu'il faudra
qu'on le fasse mais si c'est le cas on a
tout intérêt à faire en sorte que ça
arrive le plus tard possible pour qu'au
moment où on fera le fameux
déconfinement on est vacciné
suffisamment de personnes pour que
l'épidémie ne repartent pas en flèche et
qu'on soit obligé de le refaire encore
une fois derrière une dizaine
d'individus ti trentaine d'années qui
était la nôtre arrive et on commence à
commencer à nous invectiver mois
m'insulter personnellement à nous
menacer physiquement et puis aussi au
fur et à mesure à nous lancer des
projectiles ça fait un écho quand même
vraiment le fait d' évidemment
systématiquement dénoncé ces violences
qui sont et restent intolérable qu'elle
que soit quels que soient les élus qui
sont concernés aussi renforcé l'échelle
des sanctions et puis on compte aussi
sur la réponse pénale à dire il faut
derrière que la justice suive la
première photo panoramique de la planète
mars dévoilée par la nasa c'est l'oeuvre
du rover persévérance on voit la crête
du cratère de g 0 pour le lancement de
son émission ou gabriélat talent a réuni
huit mille personnes en moyenne